Hello and welcome to this video where we will be starting the exercise to populate the world,
making our forest. And for this I'm going to immediately jump straight over into the
project files so that we can kick off. So here we are back in the project.
And as you can see from the first one we should be in the Exercise 1 directory
and we should see this lovely landscape in front of us with landscape material which is grass and
this mud based on how much of a slope the landscape is. Now become more apparent as we go on.
So to kick off the first thing I would like to do is to come up into the corner here
and I'm going to click on the big plus by a cube. I'm going to search for PCG
because we're going to add in PCG volume into the world like this. Now at the moment
it's very far away from our landscape. I'm going to drag that down to our landscape
and bring it up so that it sits somewhere inside. Now this is too small for our landscape.
So I'm going to come into the details panel. So with my PCG volume selected in the details panel
here I am going to search for brush settings and that's going to bring up the size of our
of our volume. And what I'm going to do is it set to 2200, 200, 200. I'm going to change this to
10,000, 10,000, 4000. And if you look that's now not going to completely cover the landscape.
I've done that intentionally but it is going to cover a large chunk of it. So that gives us
the volume which we're going to start creating our forest in. Now there's one other setting
that I need to do. That's we need to create our PCG graph. So again with the PCG world
selected I'm going to come down and in the PCG section there is some settings. Under settings
there is a is a box for graph instance. I'm going to select the graph. Now this is blank to start
with. What I'm going to do is click on the box and you'll see at the top we have PCG graph.
I will select that and it's going to ask me where I want to place this.
I'm happy placing it in the exercise one. I'm going to ask for a name. I'm going to change
this to my PCG graph and I'm going to hit save. Now this is new in 5.6. It's going to give you
the option to start from another template. Now we're not going to do that. We're going to go
from completely from scratch. So I'm going to hit the box for create empty graph
and it's going to create me my asset here. Now we'll open that up in a minute but to start
I want to show you the finished version so we can talk a bit about how this works.
So I'm going into the finished directory and double clicking on the PCG graph.
You don't have to do this but the first thing you'll see is that we have an input and
output at the top here and we're not doing anything with this at all and these are going
to be the only nodes that you have when you first create a graph and the reason we're not
doing anything with that with this is the input and the output is only really useful
if you are going to embed this PCG graph into another PCG graph then we can use it
like a function where we hand in variables and we get out certain
but we're not going to do that for the time being so we don't have to worry about that
everything we're going to be doing is going to be self-contained within our PCG graph
Now this is what our PCG graph looks like. This will be our finished version with the commented code
and there are a couple of things that are interested about this so let's go over
the whole interface. Now to start with we have in the across the top here we have our toolbar
that's going to give us common elements like saving and finding the asset. You'll also see
you'll also see that we have the ability to pause regen and force regen that's because with
the PCG graph when you save it and update it it's going to automatically regenerate
the creation and if that takes a long time you might not want to do that every single time so
pausing regen helps you to and using the force regen means that you can test it out and create
it without having to dynamically have it updated. We're going to leave that off. Our forest is
quite small so we don't have to worry about it automatically updating. Next up on the left
here we have a viewport. Now we don't have a PCG created yet so we're not going to see
anything in this until that is done so we'll have a look at that later on.
In the middle we have our code. Now this looks a lot like Blueprints but it works
quite differently. If you've ever worked with Houdini the workflow will be familiar to you.
Where Houdini works from the top down we work from the left to the right where we have inputs
and elements on the left which we are then generating points with attributes on them
and we're using nodes throughout to update edit and filter the points and then finally
what we're doing is we're doing something with them that in this case we are spawning static
mesh instances. You can see there down the bottom we have our debug object and again
we're not going to see anything here until we have a graph in the world so we'll have a look
at that later on. On the right hand side we have our details panel that just like the rest
of Unreal Engine is going to be contextual so as you click on elements it will change to give
you the settings based on that. Okay with that said I'm going to close this down I'm going to go
back to the exercise one and then double click and open up my PCG graph. Now all we have is
our inputs and outputs I'm going to ignore them and come a bit further down. I'm going to start
off by right-hand clicking get landscape data so this is our starting point this is going to query
the landscape which is intersecting our volume and it's going to get a number of different
things we're getting the layer weights it's unbound but we are going to need to do the
output as you can see here is called concrete data subtype landscape data so this is giving us
landscape data it's not yet giving us any points and points are what we're going to be using to put
stuff down so we'll have to work on that now what I'm going to do is I'm going to drag out
of here and I am going to use a sampler node I type in sample you can see that we have an
option for a surface sample and what this is going to do is this will spread points across
the landscape now this is a good opportunity for us to talk about hotkeys now there are three
hotkeys which are important to us it is a d and e when we push a that is going to show us
what the points values and attributes are so that is for inspect so this will allow us to see the
data in the bottom debug section for that for those points at that time again that will be
denoted by a yellow dot in the top left hand corner we can push a to toggle that on and off
next up we have d and what d is going to do is it will give us a blue dot in the top left hand corner
this is going to allow us to debug and what this means is it is going to show the the bounds
meshes within the um within the world so those cubes that we can see with the the gray cubes
that's going to toggle them on and off for that node now bear in mind that you can toggle them
off on and off from multiple modes so multiple ones can be blue and we'll play around with that
a bit when we get into the engine again finally we have enable this will allow us to
turn on and off the node that we are working on by pressing e and this allows us to quickly
see the difference that a specific node makes so it's useful for for comparisons see how it's
working okay so those are the three hotkeys now if i right hand click you'll see that i actually
have a breakdown of all the hotkeys in our right hand menu and the ability tick boxes
allow us to tick them on and off now if i was to tick inspect you will see
that suddenly all of our points appear in the viewport here you can see them also you'll see
in the bottom side we've got the debug objects and on the right hand side we've got the
attributes so for this we can now see what all the values and all of the different attributes
which are applied to these points are based on that node so that's really useful and again
a we can we can swap between them so you can see in this case we have a whole landscape
i don't think earneth and turn it off again by pressing a now d if we hit d we're not going
to see anything on the left hand side here but if we jump into the world you should see our points
represented actually in the world on our landscape if we don't see it immediately you've got a under
the pcg volume try hitting the generate button just to make sure that it's there but you should
see it immediately as it goes through so that's going to indicate the placement of our points
at this point in time we will stop there at that point and next up we're going to be
building out the logic and actually spawning some static mesh instances into the world